Estas son las imágenes de árboles
quemados y tierra todavía caliente que
se han convertido en habituales en el
centro sur de chile en la última semana
el territorio que está sufriendo los
voraces incendios que según las cifras
preliminares han consumido ya más de
300.000 hectáreas lo que significa que
en una semana han quemado tanto
territorio como en dos años de fuegos
normales a lo largo de todo el país
chile es uno de los países del mundo más
proclives a sufrir las consecuencias del
cambio climático que se combinan con
diversos factores en estos fuegos en
concreto altas temperaturas históricas
que no se habían registrado en esta zona
del país nunca junto a condiciones de
baja humedad y fuertes vientos Pero
además hay 15 personas detenidas por
presunta intencionalidad en los fuegos
lo que podría explicar la gran
diversidad de focos más de 300 se han
llegado a combatir muchos de ellos
controlados y otros unos 80 en las
últimas jornadas activos por las
diversas fuerzas de brigadistas y de
bomberos desplegadas en el terreno las
cifras humanas son alarmantes más de dos
decenas de personas fallecidas más de
2.000 heridos y más de 1200 casas
completamente destruidas entre ellas 20
establecimientos educacionales en una
territorio en donde estos ya son escasos
pero la cara humana es siempre la más
dolorosa Son miles los damnificados en
esta zona de la que nos encontramos en
Santa Juana muchos de ellos viven de la
agricultura de la ganadería también el
ganado ha resultado quemado y han
perdido de esta forma No solo sus casas
y todo lo que tenían sino también su
forma de ganarse la vida las brigadas
llegan de todos los rincones del planeta
Argentina España Colombia México Ecuador
entre muchas otras pero el fuego Sigue
avanzando